Tell me about Deep Learning
ermm... maybe it can start slightly mathy
okay but uh we can just go after with an example to see what what things are right.
But
One one typical example is: if somebody wants to assess automatically what is the ehh umm price of uhh of a property?
So there are certain variables that are important for property: you know
X1, X2 to whatever.. Xn
You know, these might be:
- The square meters
- This is like ehh uhh year of construction. Whatever else, right?
and ehh...
then, the most
simple way of... of finding uhh an estimated value
is to say okay I'm gonna do this
a1, a2... aN
+
Uh usually we... you have a bias term
something like that
this gives you the estimated price, yeh?
and you can represent it like this, right?
you have the input variables
And then you have err your output variable
and then, you do this meaning that
you have this value, you have an a1 here
aN here
and all of these is summed here into the summation
Ok, so for instance, the larger the building, the higher the numberrrrrrr
the... maybe the... the newer the house
YEH
or the more valuable it is [YEH] or whatever
YEH of which floor or whatever, right?
so errhm this this is just
a weighted combination of certain factors
right? so
so uh it all comes out a big number
right?
that's [it, it will... yeh]
huh-hopefully you uh have uh more or less accurate
ehh weight, right? ehh
uhh of describing the ehh prices
so how do you ermm... ehh... learn
this thing right so you can just, you know
decide yourself to put, to put the something here
more or less what, what comes out
makes sense, right? But ehh so usually
you just find say hundred examples
right? err
if, if you're interested in doing this
maybe you have, you know, a backlog of
of, of houses sold, right?
and then you more or less you know, plot
the value in order to
visualize it we do it err... with only one
variable
which is in square meters, right?
So, you have one example here and another here
and you have, this cloud of exmples, right?
So this means that each one of these x's is
You sold a house that is...number of square meters
for this price over here
yah?
And then you try to... more or less feed that, so
so, you can say: I'm gonna do, like a straight line
that I will tell the relation between the square meters and the value
So, tomorrow if someone tells you, "you have this 80 square meter house"
there's a price, right?
Then you come here and you say, "Okay, the price is this."
Yah. Which is the best line, you don't know.
That is the question.
You say, maybe a line is not a good thing
so you will use a quadratic function, right?
Because, like, you know maybe, larger houses, there are more uhh
they are not so easy to come by so
and you still have higher ends
so, things will not go linearly
So, there's a curve line, for those who are not mathematical. It's a curve line
yes, it's a curve line that will involve more
variables, right?
and this means that you can feed things that are not so straight
so you have more flexibility in what you can model
This comes at the cost of having more variables to describe the model.
And there's always this type of relation
you have more power to represent something and then
and you can cut through a thick of relations
so how to...which kind of model is best
this is not something that is clear at all
it's not like, "just throw as many variables as you can"
and we'll feed better
because you will be doing something that's called overfeeding
which is, you would be overestimating how well you do things
so maybe if you put enough variables
and you have a set of points, right?
and then you will do this and you say
okay, I exactly predict everything
but then reality is that at some point you will get something there
and you're totally wrong
So, many parameters makes things hard
to optimize
so, in a plot structure...you have all of these
and then you have this variable that is a summation
and this is your output
and what you can do, as opposed to this, a deep structure
so a flat structure is just kind of traditional machine learning
Yeah, yeah.
Neural networks is something that has been around for a very long time.
and neural network can be either shallow
shallow is better, it's a better name
shallow structure or
or it can be a deep structure
Shallow learning, we add everything together
we come up with a number
That number gives us, "how good is this or how bad is that"
Yeah
Deep learning, other stuff's going on, right?
Yeah, so there's some variables in the middle
in between your input, the values that you are able to measure
like the size of the flat or the year of construction
and something happens that tells you some intermediate variables
and then from these intermediate variables you will get the output
you will get the prediction, or maybe
you will put yet another intermediate set of variables
and so forth
So, uhm...There are some compound concepts that might
be good for predicting
what you want to know. If you could have
direct prediction of this kind of structure
that would tell you what is the price
but maybe, the most relevant variables, in order to decide
what is the pricing is not one
of these things that were inputted
you might have to find some concepts that relate to a subset of this
in a certain way and that this is the real important
thing
so, for example, you might want to have
either a very large house with
several bathrooms
or you might want to have a small house and that  having one bathroom
is not a problem
this type of concept is a combination of more than one...you cannot decide
having one bathroom is bad
because it depends on the number of square meters of the house
the idea is that with deep learning, this thing right here will not be the price
this will be this intermediate concept
you will say, for example, I will create a concept
that you have bathrooms
and number of rooms
one one variable
and then these other things in here will not really matter
and then you can have something here that is basically
square meters...like, it's an important variable
independently of anything else
so, we will keep these. These are the only things that matter
for this variable, right?
You know, maybe the year is a really good thing to have a new flat but maybe
if the property is more than 100 years old
suddenly it becomes really good
and maybe you want to have a concept that says
"Is this a new property or..."
you will have yet another concept that says "it's a historic property", right?
and this will depend on the year but the type of relation
will be different because suddenly
it's not that old is bad
all becomes good
so you have to have all this set of intermediate concepts
in a way that now you can use them to decide
on the pricing of your house
and these will be more meaningful, more representative
of what people see
than just having the pure basic measure of things
in isolation
so, once you mix and combine some of these
will give you attributes
that are better in order to predict
but you can just do it again and again, right?
so, there's no reason why you have to combine these things
only once
and suddenly you want, I don't know, for whatever reason you might
have a lot of market for
very old houses that
actually have
an even number of rooms and bathrooms
and then you create yet another layer
so instead of having these connections directly
to the pricing of the
house, you have yet another connection
we said that we have house with
that is really old so it just went up in value because it's a historical building
and then you have a very good configuration of
rooms and bathrooms, right?
so this means that, for example, this variable here
that captures whether a good balance of rooms and bathrooms
will have a high value
we say that this variable is active
this will mean that, yeah, you have this variable active
you have this one...there was the one representing
whether the building was becoming historical
and with these two things having high value
then you have a high value also for
this variable over here
that will mean that you get really high
selling price in the end
instead, if you have a really bad
combination of room, bathroom
this variable here will have very low
value and then, instead of this variable
you will have the other one
being active and
you will have a low selling value
or lower than the other case
so these represent a kind of choices that
actually you can make
when you reason about things
So, what do you want?
We want, not only, like, square meters
rooms, bathrooms
you actually take decisions based on
the combinations, right?
so, you will say, "Well, you know, it is a large flat"
"but the distribution is really good", right?
So, this is a kind of combination of two
variables, having good distribution large
maybe if the flat was large enough you wouldn't
care so much about the distribution
and you can keep having this hierarchical
grouping of different variables
and the good thing about machine learning
is that in the same way that you reason
try to find a correlation
that will explain these things together
makes sense
the machine is able to find grouping of different variables
in a way that you basically have no idea what it means
but the machine knows that this is useful to take a decision
Right?
So, the machine is trying out various different things and you've told me what the end point is.
And it worked out what...could you
Exactly... the machine will be able to say, "Okay, in order to get an accurate prediction
you have to group these variables"
and create this kind of decision, right?
So, if you meet all these conditions
then this thing will have a high value
and whenever this thing happens and some other decisions like that
happen as well and they have high values
then this thing will happen
and you can get going really deep
in this sense, right?
Uhm, but the idea is that
You will take decisions based on these decisions
based on the input
values, right? So, you will
combine your inputs into some decisions that are intermediate
that are not really the pricing
and then you will have another
layer that will decide on the price
later on
If it tolerates you, it will give you some idea
of what's happening and you can sort of
I'm just gonna represent the other paddles...so we got two objects with the identical interfaces
one to represent the paddle on the left, one to represent the paddle on the right